there is renewed attention today on
NASCAR safety measures after that scary
crash on the final lap at Daytona which
sent driver Ryan Newman tumbling through
the air Newman is expected to survive in
part due to changes made after another
crash at Daytona and 18 years ago Manuel
Bojorquez reports from Florida's Daytona
International Speedway on those measures
there's so many areas on this car not
hardly any of it can you look at that
safety hasn't been thought of Andy
Petree has lived and breathed racing
since 1981 everywhere you can see where
a car could possibly hit it's protected
yesterday he showed us a series of
features NASCAR has installed over
several decades that he believes helped
keep Ryan Newman alive at Daytona from
padded doors this is a crush zone so it
absorbs energy when something hits the
side to window next if anything happens
in a crash it keeps the arms and things
from coming out but just if carbon fiber
seats it can stand a lot of impact
spectacular as it was we still expect
our drivers to be able to get out and
shake it off Petry was the crew chief
for the late racing legend Dale
Earnhardt senior for two years in the
90s
Earnhardt's 2001 death on the same
Daytona track sparked a safety
revolution including requiring all
drivers to use an upgraded seat belt and
harness system when you have an impact
it can keep your head from going you
know over traveling and causing bigger
injuries drivers must also wear fire
retardant racing suits and new more
crash absorbent walls have replaced
concrete around the perimeter of nearly
every track and if you think about it
race 200 miles an hour side-by-side you
can flip up in there and 99 times out of
100 these guys are getting out of the
car and walking away but you know this
time it didn't happen Petrie's company
helped build a new generation of sports
car that will be used by every drivers
starting next February but a local
sports columnist told me that he
believes speed restrictions on the race
here at Daytona keep drivers clustered
too close
together and that could remain a problem
Anthony all right man he's still
remarkable I knew we made it out of that
crash